so many things happening from the
standpoint of vaccine requirements and
mandates the big news yesterday is that
new york city will be
mandating vaccines if you want to go to
restaurants
if you want to go to gyms and if you
want to go to
most indoor entertainment type venues
new york city mayor bill de blasio
mandating coveted vaccines for certain
indoor
activities the order goes into effect
august 16th with full enforcement
starting september 13th
de blasio says the mandate known as the
key to nyc pass
would encourage increased immunizations
to combat the spread of the delta
coronavirus variant
the mayor's order comes a day after de
blasio mandated vaccinations
for all of the city's new hires
de blasio added the city will begin
inspecting businesses for compliance in
mid-september
all affected customers and workers can
either provide their vaccination cards
or upload proof of vaccination to the
excelsior
pass application new york city is
thought to be the first in the nation to
implement such a mandate
joe biden responded affirmatively when
asked at a press conference yesterday
if he believed other cities should
follow suit but stakeholders across the
food industry raise concerns about how
the program will work they are
overwhelmingly concerned about
they're saying listen this is not like
checking an id to make sure someone's
really 21 before you serve them alcohol
this is much more invasive it's going to
really affect restaurants but needless
to say
de blasio's going forward with it i
believe it will encourage more people to
get vaccinated
here is uh bill de blasio
talking about this yesterday during a
press conference this
is crucial because we know
that this will encourage a lot more
vaccination we've seen it already
we've seen the impact of the mandate
we've put in place for city workers
already starting to move people to
vaccination we've obviously
seen the positive impact of incentive as
well
the goal here is to convince everyone
that this
is the time of going to stop the delta
variant the time is now
and that means getting vaccinated right
now
this new policy will be phased in over
the coming weeks
so we've been working with the business
community getting input we're going to
do more over the next few weeks
the final details of the policy will be
announced
and implemented in the week of august
16th okay so without question
this is happening the question the
questions are how is it going to be
implemented
and how is it going to be enforced uh
new york times also writing new york
city will require
workers and customers to show proof of
at least one dose
for indoor dining and other activities
we are seeing other examples of this
as well a growing number of los angeles
restaurants and bars
are themselves requiring proof of
covid19 vaccination
microsoft will require proof of
vaccination to enter their buildings
in the united states the full opening of
its offices will be no
earlier than october 4th so they've got
couple of months
tyson foods will be mandating vaccines
for its u.s workforce we know
um that uh food processing plants were
big uh points of spread relatively
early in the pandemic so this is
happening
the questions are how will the
enforcement work and
i know a lot of you have been emailing
me saying david you know it's really
easy to forge vaccine cards
it's not only easy theoretically it's
already happening
we already are aware of all sorts of
stories of people having and presenting
fake vaccine cards so there's no doubt
that it will happen to some degree
but the point here is you know you you
put a welfare a social
insurance system in place there will be
some people who misuse it
but does it do good at the macro level
you put something like this in place
will some people lie and about being
vaccinated and get away with
it yes but they're already not
vaccinated if you incentivize a bunch of
people to go and do it we are slowing
the spread and hopefully getting beyond
the pandemic so it's happening
we will see how it all rolls out and
there is no doubt that you will continue
to see protests and more
uh there are some who are calling this
nazi-like and we will get to that a
little bit later
one of our sponsors is steady md primary
care
the easier and more affordable way to do
primary care and they're giving you
50 off because you are in my audience
you just answer a few questions steadymd
will match you with a licensed primary
care physician that's tailored to your
needs
you'll have a one-hour virtual
appointment and start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor
and from then on your doctor will be
available to you by text phone
and video chat it's not some random
doctor on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients
you get the attention you deserve and
they can help you with anything your
primary care doc
normally would it's very cool how it
works
you don't need insurance it's just 99
bucks a month
no other fees or co-pays for visits take
the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50
off your first month when you go to
steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video